and we are live man uh a historic day in
the vriends universe everybody on Tik
Tock please get over to YouTube uh a
historic day Andy K we've been on this
journey and we have now added a new
friend to our journey DJ this is uh
obviously a very exciting announcement
uh we're a lot of people in the
community are uh aware of you already
because of the way you applied for this
opportunity but we've been on a very EXC
Mission going into 2024 on character
development we have a lot coming out but
one of my favorite uh objectives and one
of my favorite initiatives in 2024 will
be the vriends daily
comic um comics in newspapers is
something I grew up with something I
loved something I read I fell in love
with Garfield and others because of it
and I really think that be friends is
built for it and I think you are just
the right man to uh do it for us and
today is a show to not
only introduce you to the V the V
friends nation which is in the chat um
not only is it to show everybody how
good Andy's haircut is currently it is
also an opportunity for us to do our
first show and we'll explain to
everybody what we mean by that but not
only will we be putting out a be friends
comic and that we'll put out into the
world and I'm personally working on the
distribution of those Comics but we're
going to be showing people the making of
the comics on an everyday basis a 2024
version of what I wish I saw I couldn't
even imagine if I was able to watch on
live stream you know the iconic
schultzes of the world doing a Peanuts
comic for the day yeah and the fact that
um we've anointed you for this role
means a lot to me want to thank Andy and
the team for going through that process
we had a lot of months and different
ways of going about it but here we are
are on a on a very instrumental day of
character development um and I'm excited
about it and I want to welcome you to
the v's uh family officially in the
organization and to the broader audience
that is now on all these socials and uh
I'd love for you to say hello Andy
anything you have to say before we
officially let DJ start saying what's up
what's up what's up um really excited
been looking forward to this day DJ
thank you for uh joining us when you
tweeted Gary I think DJ has a little
mirror board he can show of the Tweet
you tweeted out that you were looking
for a comic strip writer I started to
put together a job description of that
comic strip writer and then shout out
Jeremy Jeremy texted me at maybe 10 pm
two days following that tweet of like
hey you should check out this guy right
now he's live streaming his application
drawing for vence and right when I
jumped into that live stream uh I could
see the talent that DJ has his
understanding of vs and it really
changed how I was thinking about the
role so excited for it today excited to
continue to build out these stories
alongside Gary and DJ and I'll over to
DJ so a couple things I want to just
first get the community in here cow
Bunga good to see you PDG big shout out
to everybody on YouTube big shout out to
everybody on Twitch twitch Army say
what's up there we go little bully Squad
is in there um big shout out to
everybody on X big shout out to
everybody is linked did in Facebook in
the mix Dustin are we good are they in
the mix
I want it I want everything what do you
think that I want I even have Tik Tok
right here on my own phone looking at my
side cheeks I want it all it's a huge
day be friends is going comic
every day we're building it out DJ tell
everybody about who you are what you've
done in the past and why you're excited
about this new gig yeah J and everybody
right now give a hardcore share I want
everyone to share this on on Twitter X I
want you to take the copy of the YouTube
channel and textt your family chat
thread and say come and check this out
there's going to be a party here for the
next
hour yeah I mean first it's a blast to
even this is amazing this is an amazing
opportunity for me uh I'm DJ Kaufman I
you know from the time I was knee high
you know like Gary said looking at
Garfield and things like that I just
kind of always wanted to do Comics my
entire life so I I was I guess lucky
enough to do that very early on
full-time for like 13 years um but it's
not the most lucrative career choice I
gotta say so when you start out in
comics like it's it's very much job
after job and Publishers go out of
business and you just have to keep
hustling in that grind and um so I went
back to kind of like a day job and did
comics on the side which is totally fine
like there was a lot of um a lot of
feeling that like oh if you're not a
full-time artist you're not successful
and all that stuff but I just I just
continue to do it and continue to put
out Comics all those years but like the
newspaper stuff was always like my real
passion and like like Gary said you know
I always kind of had this vision and I
talked to my other artist friends and
I'm like guys we've got all these tools
that we can use now why aren't we going
live and
like engaging with the fans and and all
that stuff so like yeah seeing that
tweet in the middle of the night I was
just like this was the year for me like
this has been a a definitely a a pivot
year for me let's say so getting back
into what I'm passionate about and it's
not just drawing it's like the comic
strip format I think it's just very
powerful I agree my brother I really
agree uh DJ um for everybody joining on
LinkedIn and Facebook I see all the
LinkedIn Mafia here is Facebook coming
Dustin is do we have it so I can say hi
to my Facebook family Facebook family
great to see you um DJ so to restart
because there's a lot of people just
joining we are going to be doing a daily
comic strip for vriends every day and
you will be live on the vriends um live
channels Andy we definitely know we're
going to be doing YouTube and I you and
I had dinner the other night with May
and we're talking about twitch and Tik
Tok minimum Le so three platforms and
you're going to be drawing and talking
about how you're coming up with this I'm
going to be joining many of these and
kind of spit some stories that I want
you to tell and we're going to have a
lot of fun and we're going to build a
community I'm right now Twitch streaming
in mute my workday and people are
enjoying it you're G to actually be
talking along with the audience and as
you probably are very aware this
audience is
incredibly um passionate and we have a
real F fan base that's incredibly kind
and warm and I think you're about to
make a bunch of friends because you're
Monday through Fridays you're going to
be yapping along with them yeah yeah
it's an amazing I think well number one
cool day job to have doing the the daily
comic strips but just that that's
totally different than anybody else is
doing it so like it's never been done
that I've seen before so like trying to
you know it's it's quite you know I'm
glad that you have the vision for what
it could be and how important it is for
like fan engagement I think it's just G
to be different than any kind of Ip out
there it's GNA be a fun thing to hang
out and like we're going to literally
watch you make comic and then I'm going
to be working distribution obviously we
have our own channels but everyone knows
me I want to get everybody out to know
this and so I'm going to be working
behind the scenes to get these Comics
out into the wild above and beyond our
channels as a finished product and then
we got some fun collectible ideas and
everybody's contributing it's gonna be
really fun and for me it's like
going to be a fun thing because it's the
first time people are going to see
behind the curtains of how I'm thinking
about the characters for example Andy I
think we agreed that during the stream
we would get into our first one yes yes
would that be okay for me to do now
since I'm excited about it DJ are you
ready for that like like are we gon to
go right like I feel like everyone here
is like okay cool that's the
announcement we should kind of almost
live it a little bit as like an alpha
alpha one right yeah do a brainstorm
live and like check out what the chat
thinks and you know I haven't drawn all
these characters yet I gotta say you got
a lot of
characters right so how are we gonna
actually let them see how the the
pudding is made if if you wanted to show
DJ if you wanted to show your mirror
board I don't know if that's the best
place you you you can do a little recall
on how we got here uh the comic that you
made and I know Gary you have a couple
characters in mind specifically so this
is the tweet that we had mentioned um
and you can just tell your POV
DJ yeah so that's the tweet that Gary
put out I screenshotted it just for you
know documentation and uh so I I was
sick in the middle of the night by the
way couldn't sleep and uh I was thinking
about this because I I I'd gone to vcon
this year but on a whim you know like I
didn't really wasn't expecting to go
there and kind of went and I I
experienced the the
vibe uh my my wife got an extra ticket
and I just kind of had just changed jobs
so I was like oh I can just go hang out
and see what's up with Gary how did she
get the extra ticket uh she worked for
Benny
fiser who you're familiar with get out
of your house she recently got laid off
that's another another story sorry s
diser finagle way into this Andy once
again anyway go ahead D yeah so yeah he
had he had had an extra ticket and said
hey does your husband want to go and I'm
like well yeah you know I want to check
it out and I just kind of went I Had No
Agenda I just wanted to enjoy the show
but I got to meet like Bobby H hundreds
and Ed balloon and like talk to a bunch
of like nft artists and stuff like that
so it was really cool like Brian uh
Brian Brinkman and listen to a lot of
good speakers and um so so that was my
first kind of like oh what is this
vriends thing like this is awesome like
the vibe was totally awesome the
speakers were great vcon was just like
really life-changing for me just like
you know getting into meditation and
like just changing my up my you know
mental game a little bit by the way let
me just jump in here and do a vcon
commercial let me do it for Tik Tok too
vcon ve
n.co everybody please link up vcon ve ve
. vcon 2024 August 8th to the 11th Los
Angeles California it is going to be
remarkable everybody needs to come not a
single person that is on right now
should miss it go ahead
D yeah so like I said I came back from
that and then I went to vidsummit I got
a lot of like friends at vid Summit and
you know you guys are all saying the
same kind of thing like you should be
working on your passion while I had the
cool day job and like marketing and
stuff like that and I'm prettyy good at
that um I my passion when I would walk
away from these shows was comic strips
not necessarily drawing but like nobody
wants a four panel comic strip anymore
you know that kind of thing so when I
saw that I was just like middle of the
night I just started sketching the
characters up you know right away like
two two o'clock in the morning I'm like
because I know I know what's up like I'm
like they want to see action like let's
go like let's not fool around here and
go how do I submit and like back and
forth like the old school ways let's
just start doing it and like what did I
have to lose you know like I'm just
going to draw some cool characters so
these were the first time I drew uh any
of the V friends how
long now for sure I've got a story that
I want to share today that we're gonna
make into a comic ASAP to the best of
your
ability um in the future let me I'm
sorry to interrupt you but I'm just Andy
I'm sorry I'm just too excited how long
like I know humble Hedgehog I want in
the first one I'll explain in a minute
how long will it take you from because I
I'm making pretend it's January 10th and
I'm on with you and I'm like okay humble
Hedgehog tells optimistic otter and
creative crab I'm gonna give you some
themes and I'm let you go if you've
never drawn creative crab if I come on
how like will we have to prep beforehand
or can I spit it in real time like how
are we gonna have to do it so it's
entertaining for everyone and you can
actually pull off your actual job of
getting a comic out each day yeah I mean
I think if I've never drawn the
character before I think even before we
had a little meeting earlier today and
they told me about some of the
characters that would be on today so I
was like I gotta hurry up and draw the
the Fox right and like Common Sense C
last night and I'm pissed at Andy for
this he's like hey because I just want
to improv it I just want to show up on
the DJ show at like 10. and be like all
right d I'm really feeling driven dragon
and honestly like creative crab needs
some love and like even more fun you
know what we're gonna do D I just
thought of this right now we're GNA do
pack shows where I open a
pack and you've just got to make one of
the African
civit okay the
hery yeah the sperm whale I mean got
real stories to tell about the whale and
the forever Phoenix like I think that
would be funny yeah I think
to get like a sketch of it like a a
sketch going probably 10 or 15 minutes
of looking at the character and kind of
figuring out how the shapes are and
stuff like that and I can get enough to
awesome I can get enough to you know do
like a loose here's here's like
basically a rough draft you know I kind
of worked on the you know what what
would the the comic be um and then it
just starts to
like I don't have these in layers right
now this is just a screenshot but this
was the first comic like a Sunday comic
sort of thing and it was just a real
simple concept because I had no
direction from anyone there was nothing
except for your Tweet by the way quick
this is what V doesn't understand I
don't know if you see this V says Gary
just stressed him out the reverse This
Is What DJ lives for this oh yeah love
it part of the v's family do you
understand in the same way that you all
love jery and you fall in love with rips
like DJ is gonna be in you're gonna be
drinking coffee with DJ like and he's
gonna be in the background while you're
work this is gonna be insane this is we
were coming to life in a 1950s classic
way do you know how awesome this is
gonna be wait till you see the I've
already got my idea for this first scrip
I can't wait for everyone to hear what
I'm about to say it's good yeah
uh yeah I'm I'm built for this because I
mean I even went to like like I said 13
years full-time at Comics going to
comiccons and like doing fan art for
people like on the Fly having to like do
some pretty nice fan art and stuff for
people like it's pretty saying it's easy
DJ's gonna laugh at me and do two a
day I want to get ahead you know I
definitely want to get ahead that's the
that's the game
right oriented octopus they exist for a
reason
too uh
yeah so this is the pencils you know so
I do it I do it very traditionally I
draw the pencils first on the iPad I
draw I'll draw for you here in a second
but uh pencils you know inks and then
colors so the coloring takes a little
bit longer um so I don't know if we'd
get all that done this is like I think
just because this is for the hardcore
Community we're gonna obviously build
over the next months and years but we're
thinking four panel like how in a day
because we really are like excited about
this day are we thinking four panels is
that how we're going to get done are you
going to be ambitious some days and go
to six to tell the full story how are
you thinking about it yeah I'm actually
thinking like classic daily strip you
know so like the Monday through Friday
or Monday through Saturday would be four
panels and then you got your Sunday
that's bigger whatever whatever it could
be so uh we were talking a little bit
about it but it could be a theme it
could be one shots it could be the color
again it's amazing like show
color one again look look look at this I
love I love the story when they send
cynical Cat To The Moon that was funny
yeah I just like I was drawing it
actually and I just heard Gary somewhere
on like a podcast say like he hates
cynical cat and I'm like so uh I I
was like okay I'm gonna cynical cats so
much that I love them that's for the
collectors out there you hate cynicism I
hate cynicism but I secretly love
Skeletor and the Joker like anyway well
that's why I decided I'm like all right
well I already learned to draw the cat
so we're just going to blast him off
into space Jay
J says Saturday comic idea from the
community every week yeah look we're
going to definitely play with the
community I'm gonna I'm going to use
this as a format to tell some stories to
really get you some behind the scenes of
where this is all going but we'll have
some fun we're definitely gonna have fun
where people can earn their way into
being they'll be freeways to like we're
gonna we're gonna have some fun this
this is a real evolution of the IP in a
really way and yes DJ is crazy talented
look how good this looks go ahead D
there's a cameo of dinner deer here I
mean you know I know he's just like a
one-off card or whatever but uh dinner
deer and uh this was a good gag made me
laugh I got to give credit to my wife
because she was like looking at this
character and she's like what if his
head was the size of his hat and I was
just like all right so that was the that
was the the joke at the end was a con
now I had no idea if that was like in
the you know in the character bio or
whatever I was just like this is just a
submission I thought it was funny
there's a lot of stuff that working on I
keep telling everyone look Daredevil was
yellow and red when he first came out
sure so like I'm not going to be
petrified on something's changing along
the way and so we're gonna have some
Freedom with these Comics but yes
there's gonna be a lot of alpha drop on
these
shows yeah so this is also what I sent
you guys like just to so the audience
can kind of see and I I asked Andy I was
like do you guys want to go full behind
the scenes and give the full you know
plan that I pitch so you know you got
daily V friends right Monday through
Saturday four panels um there you go
that's all the and then Sunday like we
just said and then this kind of thing
like as far as how many strips that
equals and how many panels that's 364
strips a year story arcs you know it
could be rapid development of your
characters wait a minute 364 are you
taking Christmas off or like I'm
confused I think that's just how it
worked out I did the math I was like how
many
days there's 365 days a year d
well I yeah yeah right I don't know
there's 312 dies I said how many days
are in 2024 but yeah um yeah math you
know I'm a cartoon scary math do art I
get it right I let you guys handle the
math so uh you know quarterly print
editions like and then I said like hey
why not create it live stream to T to
YouTube twitch meta wherever you can U
screen stream to um and then future
maybe we go like do the old school
ComiCon visits School visits I don't
know like it would have been cool like
if I had a cartoonist come to my school
and like you know Little Talks or
whatever and then basically I just you
know you guys get the distribution model
like a lot be just fine on that
part and then my you know my confidence
is that we'll be bigger than Garfield in
20 years so like just let's just do this
for 20 years and see what happens um and
Crush peanuts so I love peanuts I love
gar don't give
up with same thing I I did a video the
other day that helped clarify to some
people on Twitter I want to Aspire to
Pokemon in Marvel why wouldn't I right
of course we want to Aspire to peanuts
and Garfield and like you know then your
talents and reality of Life land you to
where they land you but you know that's
we're gonna do that by the way back to
like life um let's do this um I am going
to uh actually actually I like this I'm
going I'm going Bon Barnes Bon Barnes
I'm giving you all four of these cards
right now surprise
I'm get in here somebody grab this from
so I don't lose these and and I'm gonna
sign one right across it there we go
assigned forever Phoenix all four of
these cards are going free to Von Barnes
team can make sure that gets done
somebody come in here and grab these I
know you're somebody's watching this
come make sure I don't screw this up and
there we go Andy might have to come in a
minute congrats B all right keep going
uh yeah so like I said about half an
hour ago or something like that I was
just starting to learn this the first
time I drew the fox I start with just
like basic shape I'll I'll make that a
little bit better that's little fade out
I'll start with like the basic shape of
your character you know like what what
they're made out of basically and just
kind of build up on top of
the first time I drew the fox same thing
with um the Hedgehog and the
cow comment
cow yeah so we can we can get right into
like this morning I was working a little
bit because I'm just kind of just
getting familiar with let me tell you
the story that the team said hey let's
give even though I want to go in impr
the team's like give us a premise of
where you're going I know where I want
to go for the first comic I'd love for
you to tell the story I'm going to share
with the whole right now you ready yeah
all right the characters that are going
to be in the first comic are going to be
Flex Fox Common Sense cow and humble
Hedgehog okay and the premise of this
episode is that Flexin fox is like
concerned about not having enough
money and Common Sense cow and humble
Hedgehog are going to be
helping flex and fox and so some of the
things that are bouncing in my mind the
the punch line of the joke is I want
them to ask him how many streaming
services he's on so one of the things
each excited about with this comic is
we're g to make V friends very
contemporary and very sharable as like
memes and jokes people when we put out
on social so the punchline of this is
humbled hedgehog keep it humble and
Common Sense cow keep it common sense
are gonna flex and fox is sad and and
it's like I don't have any money one of
the two
characters are asking well of course you
don't you buy dumb or stuff you
don't
need fox is like no you obviously
not in that we keep it kidfriendly
and and one of the other charact hum the
coward or the Hedgehog says Fox how
manying services do you have and fox
rattles off like all nine of them all 30
of them I want to like really make that
a big joke and then and then they're
like that's a problem you don't even
watch peacock you know and then maybe
the Practical peacock and make an
appearance the background be like hey
then and then he fixes that it's kind of
like that's the punchline it's a story
that everybody in the world like hey you
have too many streaming services like
that's one of your problems which is
real problem for even the people like
the amount of people on this right now
DJ that have three too many ready just
watch this in the comments comments how
many streaming services are you paying
for right now please put it
Lulu you're you're getting a little
choppy on the audio i'mna ping I am it's
just just cutting in and out on static
see it's really strange because it
sounds fun I'm Mayan and I don't know if
you guys can hear each other perfectly
fine we can hear each other fine D it's
just I just uh yeah that's why I'm not
I'm trying to figure it out I don't know
what it is
exactly that never happened before is
still happening yeah it seems like it's
happening for everybody is it still
happening
that's I know I didn't want but it was
getting kind of
choppy all right we is it it's still
happening too bad DUS will continue to
try to figure out what's going
on I'll just try to work through it but
obviously we'll
um we'll figure out like how choppy is
it should I like should we like really
really wait or is it predominantly
understandable well it's good for TI to
Tik Tok you guys are good
right you guys are probably all
good um DN yeah it's pretty rough it's
it plugs in on
YouTube so we should
wait that's too bad yeah I kind I want
to wait but I also want to give DJ the
head start on uh the vision for these
but I I think you sort of got the the PA
of he doesn't have enough money but he's
subscribed to all these Services as a
luxury yeah a little peacock popping in
all right yeah no I think that's uh
that's the perfect example here I could
just like as I'm showing like I don't
know if anybody could see now with this
but all right great um so I start with
like real basic rough shapes like we're
just calling them roughs but like that's
how I would like
quickly sketch that but I go to a pencil
layer and then I'll just start the um
and I'm just doing this for memory right
now as far as um the fox's basic shape
you know like he's got
some if we're gonna make him look sad
too we gotta kind of he's not uh this is
too bad I'm like sad I lost my whole
Mojo no don't don't be sad don't lose
your mojo
you're exced and they're bearing through
it nobody excit Andy it's
over that's a very cynical cat take of
you I'm just realistic still
excited I need a lot more still excited
in the comments yo Chad can we drop a
still excited little choppiness will not
ruin this moment thank you soggy waffles
don't be down just twitch switch to
Twitch Mojo time can't wait I'm excited
cheerful chipmunk Jet's face don't lose
it just sir's
excited Christopher is it just the audio
that was chopping
yeah honestly the live streaming aspect
is absolutely sick I agree Landon W
shout out DJ for bringing it to
life still excited Gemma Luis don't be
saggy shroom Factory let's go Patron is
excited Elizabeth is excited Chef is
excited it's getting better David says
it's getting better wait is the audio is
my audio maybe I'm the is the audio
getting better is it getting better give
us a a real V check it's better on
Twitch talk
softer Andy you're like at control like
Calment
down things never heard before right
listen fine I'll tell the story again so
flexing Fox is upset because he's broke
Common Sense cow and humble Hedgehog are
like Yo dude one of the problems is you
buy dumb fox is like what are you
talking about common sense cow's like yo
bro you have 13 streaming services you
don't
actually use any of
them wait a minute yeah I feel like I
feel like mine is still not working is
that true or am I back your
back YouTube is the roughest people on
Twitch are hearing very
well still excited shout out Camila
camil is an amazing USR you guys don't
know you should check her out yeah she's
great all right yeah twitch is rocking
go so he's on 11 Services make could
joke but peacock practical peock peacock
makes an appearance then basically DJ
they fix it through that but then at the
end a a door Dash driver comes and
delivers peacock like a bagel I mean
delivers flexing Fox a bagel and the
like the receipt is like $6 Bagel $22
delivery charge $13 Char like it's a $60
bagel and like it's like the punch line
is streaming service
joke kind of fixed it because you see
him like unsubscribe from all of them on
the phone and then he's like I have to
one more thing but we don't realize he
orders a bagel on seamless or Postmates
or door Dash door Dash delivers maybe
it's a be character maybe it's not and
then Common Sense cow and and and hot
are pissed and are like what the
got it so the point yeah the thing I'm
most excited about everybody who's
listening and watching is we're going to
use the be daily comic to talk about
generic things but also we're GNA talk
about
um you know pop culture of the moment
yeah yep and to and
to and to Jared's Point yes the fox's
time is not worth that much money yet uh
and he's complaining about being Brooke
to me if you don't complain you can do
whatever you
want Andy that's like that whole $8
coffee thing when people would see me
like you have $8 coffee I'm like I'm not
complaining about
money it's the people complain about not
having money that are buying $8 copes
that are making a mistake so that's
that's the gist and and D that's what I
really want out of this strip like I
want to talk about pop culture events
like the Superbowl and you know like
Taylor Swift concerts and we're going to
really make V friends come to life in
what's going on in pop culture for
sharability on social and like inside
mom jokes and all that good
stuff yeah yeah I said earlier maybe
you'll have uh Taylor Swift kind of in
the background just in the background no
no reason why she's just kind of in the
background maybe it'll make a lot of
people watch her strip you know J Jinger
is
saying they just added the new feature
on got it so we took Rim off because you
couldn't hear anything on there got it
it was Instagram that was killing us
Instagram okay thank you brother um um
jinger's asking will we talk about the
bills who had a great win we will Ginger
we'll inevitably wait till late January
when Josh Allen and the bills choke
again and we'll use Brave bison to make
another joke about how much the bills
can never win the big game ouch
yes I would say the dialogue will change
oh go ahead
sorry I was going to make a joke when V
friends comments uh match Gary's
Vendetta against NFL
teams
yeah I what I think that's a good point
Andy Gary B being mad at Juicy Jaguar
when the Jaguars beat the Jets could be
like a whole
thing so who are the we have common
sense cow in this we have humble head
hog and we have flex and fox hold on
Frank Rosado said three Super Bowl
losses in a row for the bills Frank is
wrong it was four Andy do you know those
were all four of my high school years
freshman is senior and I hate the bills
because they're in the Jets division I
had to watch them go to four super you
know what high school is for fandom
that's like the prime time I'll never
like everyone's like why are you mad at
the bills they were so bad for 20 years
I'm like I remember when they were
great would you rather
take four Super Bowl losses or no Super
Bowl appearances four Super Bowl losses
yeah the bills have it way better than
Jets
yeah oh I like this I fully believe in
this yes Matt first of all I think
everybody here who's got a vfriend
series one in the chat leave a say yes
bf1 if you
do but yes Matt you should definitely
get a logical lion
100%
what's good highs good to see all of you
thank you for joining we are on YouTube
and twitch and a bunch of other
platforms live where DJ our new comic
for V friends is in real time making the
comic of the day we're going to be doing
a comic of the day for vriends my
pokimon Marvel IP world and I'm excited
about it it's GNA be real character
development it's gonna be a lot of
social media content we're going to
bring a lot of awareness to the
ecosystem Andy I don't know if you're
noticing but I'm buying up a good amount
of V friend Series 2 to give out as
Santa Claus this season so look for me
around Christmas where I'm going to ho
ho ho and give people the ability if
they're committed to making their be
friends their avatar on Twitter I I feel
like there's a lot of I just saw too
many people say they can't afford a be
friend series two it's one thing for a
series one it's thousands of dollars but
a series two is obviously you know
hundred bucks couple hundred bucks and
you know that really affected me and I
like there's just a lot of friends I've
made on social media so I'm going to do
a little bit of Santa Claus um action I
was recalling the Santa V meme we made
back in the day on team Gary ve I feel
like we need to bring that back yeah I
think I think some people need to be
awarded on Christmas or around Christmas
Christmas Eve the day after Christmas
I'm really planning some downtime with
some hot cocoa and uh just gonna sit
there with my account and reward people
with a free series two and I'm hoping
I'm excited for people to uh pick up
some series ones obviously you know
what's going on in 2024 it's GNA be a
good year and I'm excited about people
discovering be friends through DJ's work
here look at look at this is this fun to
watch him by the way de when you're
gonna do these streams how long do you
think you're gonna be on every
day I don't know because I think I'll
probably I I like to wake up early so I
don't know if like I might do like the
sketching and then do the inking and
coloring live so maybe I'll be on for an
hour or two or we'll figure it out like
whatever's you know I don't want to take
up the whole Channel but um no no I with
it like I know Gary wants you live 247
365 so you're not all right we're g
gotta bount some cameras in here I do
like the idea of actually the sketching
part because I'll be available in the
mornings I think a lot more likely and
so I can come on and do what I just did
here so for a lot of you this was choppy
I'll do it again the concept is
obviously I want to give DJ a lot of
freedom but I obviously don't want to
take him him to take the characters too
far and obviously as the Creator I gotta
we'll be doing a lot of behind the
scenes work where he'll get a sense of
these characters but I want to come on
multiple times a week in The First
beginning and just be like what I just
did here now which was a version of this
which was hey today's comic I really
want to talk about people not saving
money and not being practical so let's
use flexing Fox and let's use common
sense cow and humble Hedgehog the
biggest issue I see right now is people
are ordering food from seamless and Uber
Eats and Postmates and they have too
many live streaming services so
everybody in the chat right now all 500
of you please tell me what streaming
services you're paying for right now
because the joke of this comic and the
observation of social commentating is
we're trying to get flexing Fox to not
be broke anymore one of the ways we're
GNA do that is get him to cancel seven
of his 11 streaming services or eight
out of nine and then the punchline joke
at the end is just as we got him there
he stayed on his phone even though he
canceled them all he ordered a bagel and
paid $31 for a bagel just like many of
you do who are complaining about money
or you have friends and family or kids
that complain about money but they're
buying $31 Bagels between sir charges
and fee and up charge and fuel charge
and Sir charge and Rain charge and so
that's we're we're touching the issues
in society what people can't have money
on are we cheer rips is 21st birthday
rips get in here get in here
now come on it's Rip's 21st
birthday it does add up Jared all right
rips get in here I know everybody knows
this young man today is his 21st
birthday rips take the seat little
dj your 21st birthday okay uh it's
another day in the
life Brown Goods let's go is it good yes
it's 21 years age yeah I got this for
you you don't even
know um this is awesome I'm excited to
have Danny or DJ is what's the D and
D why did I intuitively say Dan
I don't know let me give you a massage
on your birthday so here's what's
happening I'm not a big birth I'm not a
big celebrator okay oh we're live here
too what's up so rips flex and fox is
upset because he has no money okay there
he is humble Hedgehog and Common Sense
coward like yo bro you have nine
streaming services like you don't need
Max agree like you're not
watching enough a you know
peacock yeah then we make the peacock
joke practical peacock po something goes
hey not so practical after all um so
then humble Hedgehog and Common Sense
cow team up to help him finally cancel a
bunch of them right yeah and then we're
watching he kind of cancels him on his
phone everyone's all happy they feel
like we did a good thing and then a
delivery man pulls up and
delivers a bagel because while he was
cancelling he ordered a bagel on
seamless and bought a $39 Bagel because
you know what that's that's how it
happens when you buy you know well
how do you feel about being 21 uh I'm
not a big birthday for I don't know I
know I like you you know I hate my
birthday yeah I don't like I'm like you
feel like did when you heard me talking
about that you were like oh a same um
you don't like being you don't like
being wished happy birthday before your
birthday which I don't mind the same way
but for me I'm like I think it's like
forced attention that like you don't
really want I feel like I didn't earn
any like I like I just told someone it's
unearned attention
yeah
Andy we like to day trade for our
attention over here we like to earn our
over here
you didn't earn these beautiful blue
eyes come on show them look at these
eyes look at these guys show it look at
those uh you didn't earn those you act
you act like the patient Panda doesn't
have blue eyes because of me and I I
think it's funny that you act that way
don't don't give up don't give
up okay rips tell everybody because a
lot of these people collect admit that
over dinner with me you may
Andy trout and sonan yeah that I came up
with a brilliant idea that we're working
on right now yes that is going to make
April to August
exciting more than exciting yeah no
extremely exciting extremely ex and you
agree like you were you were massively
impressed with my brainstorming ability
and the Brilliance we came up with well
I'm at the point in my career where I'm
not necessarily I'm not easily impressed
I'm more would just be upset with rips
and my rips and myself that we didn't
get to that point ourselves but I'm
excited I think it's the right strategy
and uh a lot of the current collectors
and fans are going to be excited and
with DJ
the the duo between DJ and Adam actually
and the Synergy that's going to happen
which we yet are to fully understand and
grasp because the just the chemistry and
creative Synergy I think is going to be
very very exciting what are you
doing
orchestrating conducting
orchestrating he's in the front octopus
doing this oh orchestrating octopus
could have been so cool orchestrating it
could have been all I could have
put the thing in all the
it would have killed people
would have managers would have loved
that
well what are you doing for the big
day uh I'm going to dinner after with
Aton I'm aware I heard oh really yeah I
know everything I know where you are at
all
times most of the time but DJ how's the
comic coming along good good so we got
the fox here he's looking a little sad
because he's broke right I think seen
the fox with the
uh expression and I think it's cool yeah
I like it yeah Hedgehog wants to help
out right yep and then Common Sense Cy's
GNA be like all right let's break it
down and then the next panel would be
like how many streaming services you
have yeah and then Fox will be counting
Counting his fingers you know like going
like one two three like whatever hold on
hold on and then at the I wanna I want
to just pin this just Dash I just want
to apologize that this sucks I don't
know if you talk if you're talking about
Rip's 21st birthday DJ's drawing which I
doubt because it's remarkable it could
be Andy's haircut which I think is
insane because it looks phenomenal it's
probably me so I just wanted to pin your
comment up here and apologize and hope
you're having a good day brother hope
all hopeall is incredible on your end
all right go
ahead yeah so then and by the way these
are roughs here guys don't judge me on
the rough pencils here and I haven't
drawn these characters before so you
know it's not
DJ don't do that stop stop doing that
this is so remarkable it's like
insane to me yeah it's you know I'm us
hey whatever like I know what I'm doing
so uh so then yeah at the very end we'll
have the receipt from the uh it'll be
like a closeup of the receipt of all the
maybe just the one thing that he bought
that's like 30 bucks or something yeah I
really want the bagel to be like
everything bagel extra locks Peppers
papers like I want to be really funny
and I really want it to be like
legitimately like four $3 I don't know
if you know this but in New York if you
order a bagel like from like Uber Eats
or Postmates it's like $40 it's
crazy yeah yeah you know that right
re I mean yeah you're too smart yeah you
got you got the dollar
Bagels there's a good amount of three or
four three or four seems like the uh
average number of Ott
subscriptions people are having in the
chat yeah yeah I think that's right by
the way that's what I'm with like being
in the business but I want the joke here
to be that fox has like 11 and DJ this
will be fun like like obviously we're
like very early in making this like I
really want it like this is where like
you can you have Partners now you're not
just doing this solo you can text back
to our team on a team thread and be like
I need I need help knowing like what
other like nobody's thinking about like
the
Zone the you know the zone is one for
sure I by the way I have that because
Sports and have the Zone but like Flex
and chat let us know which streaming
service you're paying for that's like
tier six yeah it reminds me of like is
crackle a
service I don't know it reminds me of uh
like proactive piranha could come in and
like I I get to I do like a lot of free
trials and then I forget to cancel them
and I'm like PayPal just charged me 12
bucks like I'm the I'm the laziest could
be proactive piranha can like swoop in
and tell
me set your not set your you're not in
the C no I can be for your birthday
maybe next year I don't no no I'm saying
I'm relating another character to this
so what' you do today on your birthday
worked yeah I was up late are you gonna
do any special uh if you pull a
character that has a a 21 score I have a
great idea interesting I'm going to do
some oh you're wait a minute you're
going live soon yeah half hour we're
going we're going back to back now yeah
I'm sorry I forgot everyone grips is
gonna be live on his 21st birthday in 35
minutes it's doing pack breaking but I'm
I'm giv rip double
header I'm giving rips a Packer's
birthday I want let's go rips let's go
one of one one one you imagine let's go
rips let's go
rips persistent all we got persist got
short print we got a rookie 21 in skill
got a rookie 21 in skill R Rip's got a
penguin in him for sure that is the Jo
joyous jellyfish another 21 let's see if
we can go all
21s nice pull okay I like to go as as oh
no 21's there but I'm gonna get it as
early as I can that is the boss Bobcat I
like the boss Bobcat the boss Bobcat we
haven't done much with we're opening
these we're opening we only have seven
boxes worth today that's why we're doing
a lot of giveaways we're doing a lot of
giveaways in some games yeah by the way
we're doing a ton of giveaways for Rip's
birthday I'm close up here yeah here we
go final one 56 that's the
Civic oh I was wrong the R long dog the
Dapper rare long
dog yeah half hour on the Fanatics Live
app we're literally we're going to be
giving away a lot of slabs TI to rip
seeds birthday series one box Live app
we're gonna be live shortly follow V
friends uh on all platforms are we be
friends cards on Tik Tok or we still be
friends be friends cards everywhere so
be so Tik Tok is now be friends cards
yeah and Andy you saw Instagram now is
be friends cards and verified
I'm aware I mean people almost lost
their jobs around
here Tyler Schmo wants to know why can
nobody word
Dash people no people say it's dachon do
do yeah everyone says daxin it's a Doxon
do get the out of here it is a
dox I thought it was like a weener dog
yeah but a lot of people say dashound I
thought it was a dashound
it's a docit like the
reindeer all right fine get out here
okay I'll see you I love you happy
Birthday brother thank you appreciate it
Happy Birthday rips see you on Fanatics
live at 5:55 I don't know we're live
yeah half hour yeah rips is live in 23
minutes we're giving away a ton of free
collectibles in honor of rips like an
obnoxious amount so make sure you get
the Fanatics app uh there it is there's
the link Gary
e.com fanatics1
1219 um make sure you download the app
get on Fanatics live we'll be live there
in 22 minutes you're taking some fre I
mean I want to selflessly aution a lot
of stuff but we might just I'm not
giving up this no I'm not a
classic look at this everyone that's a
classic Toronto and St Louis I'm just
looking I'm admiring The Collection no
worries
all
right uh everybody help everybody find
the app because a lot of people are
asking where is it um Colin what's
good what is good Daniel um is everybody
set with the app and by the way you're
gonna have to create an account to get
free stuff it's a big thing rips and
conman and Courtney they'll do a good
job onboarding you does who's who's
downloading the app right now for the
first time to join rips on his
birthday you better this will have a
good comic STP day it is so fun
oversight pills what I don't have a good
this is a Beauty look at this
character to develop because it's a very
oh pondering from all angles is a beast
I've got a I've got a comic for
him that is AA he's a he's a great Comic
character too I agree you can also like
look at all the panels like there'll be
something to do meanwhile DJ is just
cruising along here with this comic
if you're just joining us uh we just
announced today that we are starting a
daily comic for V friends with our man
DJ here DJ Koffman has joined the team
he is like actively drawing right now
the first comic that we're gonna put out
DJ when when will this come out
tomorrow I think maybe tomorrow yeah
because we I'll finish it up I'll finish
up some of the art uh tonight and then
we'll do a live stream tomorrow at noon
I think so I don't know where I'll let
you guys decide where to send people but
we'll be finishing up live on the stream
tomorrow and uh we'll be right back here
be friends YouTube you know what's cool
about this Andy let's make sure when J
on that we also bring like we program
guests like rips can come on for 30 talk
about cards right Jeremy can jump on and
talk about what's going on like there's
a way to like if he's on for three four
hours we could have a lot of fun we
could bring on we can do some Q&A
because it's cool because he's like it's
also like fun for people to learn like I
feel like a lot of people are going to
learn how to draw through this like this
is insane what he's doing right now this
like fun Lear I'm so excited about the
when I first watched DJ's stream he was
active in the chat he was drawing he was
looking at the comments and there was
this whole iterative Community uh
Centric creation which I'm really
excited about I think even for this I
was gon ask you if you want to throw any
Easter eggs asking about what's
happening next let me just show you you
guys hang keep everybody entertained
Dany um Tik Tok what's going on next
is you're on 2 it' probably be hard to
catch up with like 2,000 comments
compared to my stream my smaller stream
but DJ I wanna I want to go back to your
origin story a little bit so you yeah
came to Deon and that's really where you
first learned more about be friends and
the be friends audience but you've been
following Gary for a while
now oh sure I mean I I followed Gary for
you know man long time really long long
time from like the very first Gary ve
show like the the Ask Gary ve show and
um all the books so I've got his books
over on the Shelf too so yeah marketer
by by profession I guess
so yeah very familiar with
Gary and I think at some point Gary go
ahead I think some point Gary put out
content where he's like stop listening
to me like stop watching me and I was
like okay and then I just went ahead and
just did my own thing that's kind of
when I got serious about my stuff so
yeah I love it and what you can share a
little bit about like the current
platform that you have with draw or die
and like what the goal and vision was
for that was for that for
you yeah so I run a brand called Draw or
die which is like a motivational brand
for artists um I had a lot of artists
reach out to me and like you know
they're feeling are kind of stuck art
you know artwise art block um and I was
always putting out stuff so they would
reach out and say like how do I you know
get over this funk that I'm feeling and
I would just I was always messaging
artists back so uh and I had different
exercises that I would give them to
scribble challenges and things like that
um and that that kind of started there
and then um from there I just listened
to the audience and they're like can you
give us merch you know so I made some
shirts and like notebooks and stuff to
kind of keep them motivated so uh we run
that out of the uh we run that out of
the house and uh my my wife does all the
Fulfillment so that's pretty uh I love
it love her for doing that so what about
this prototype that will not be
happening but it's fun to show people
behind the scenes some prototypes of
things that will not be happening but I
know people would like
this fresh
one yeah that would have been cool but I
snaped this one this was a no
but you know I was working on some
stuff in in which app are you drawing
DJ I draw in uh procreate on the iPad
Pro so I probably do 95% of my artwork
on the
iPad
but definitely still approach it you
know with like pencils that inks that
colors like just traditional traditional
cartooning working on
Jackson uh for everybody on Tik Tok this
is we're live on YouTube and other
platforms we're about to go live on
Fanatics live giving away a bunch of
cards make sure does anybody need help
that's in the US because I know the app
is not available in outside the US
though people can watch on desktop right
Andy yes International people can watch
on desktop they're not gonna be able to
participate in some of the breaks and
stuff but it's a great place to learn
about V friends engage with the
community you just won't be able to
participate in purchasing any of the the
breaks and what Adam and Connor have
planned for today yep manag to do
um how come you've been leaning into
twitch more lately honestly because um
I'm always trying to expand I finally
figured out what I want to do on Twitch
the fact that I'm in my office a lot
more I'm able to stream now um because I
was traveling so much before which is
why I was able to do daily B ironically
I have a ton of travel coming in the
first quarter of the year I um
I met with my team last night and I got
a ton of
travel I'd be curious in the chat if you
if we were only going to stream on one
platform vriends Comics what
platform would you prefer it to be or do
you think it should
[Music]
be Gary I have a question for you go
ahead uh when was the moment you decided
like think you you said you thought
about be friends for a long time like do
you remember the moment where you're
like I could do this like I could put
out this whole IP this whole universe
curious it started it started in I mean
it's been blur blurry in my mind since
17 Andy I think it was 2019 or 18 we had
that meeting with the toy Guy where I
wanted to do workplace Warriors right
fall
2019 yeah so fall of
2019 um I I had a meeting and it was
probably about a year that we were
talking about it prior to that so it was
that was like the meeting of like this
this is happening yeah I would say
somewhere in 1617 it started to become a
thought what I what I knew was that
people were sending me too much content
about being unhappy at work and I wanted
to make these two inch three-inch
figures to put on people's desk and make
them think about compassion and empathy
like I would DM someone back and be like
they're like my boss is a dick I'm like
I'm like maybe your boss is going
through a divorce maybe your boss just
found out his mom is terminally ill
maybe your boss just got yelled at by
his or her boss and so I was like look
there's no reason to be a dick but if we
don't have a capacity to be
compassionate back to people well then
then we're we're just contributing to
bad behavior and so and then people R
like that's amazing Gary like thank you
like I actually went and talk to my like
I would get really intense DJ like
you're were so right like it'd be
something else right like their daughter
their daughter is I remember one I'll
just share it it's a little challenging
but he was like oh my God I asked my
boss like are you okay and he broke down
crying this guy that I've always thought
was Hardcore and everything and it was
because his daughter was cutting
herself oh and this was just a DM I do
that a lot I engage with people a lot
and I was like and so I was like man if
I could just make five or six characters
and put them on people's desks at
work compassion empathy entrepreneur elf
like if you look at entrepreneur elf
maybe one day you'll quit and be an
entrepreneur like or compassionate
catfish like so that's how it started
then covid happened and then obviously
the nft thing happened I've been
following it from crypto kites back in
17 and then NBA Top Shot kicked off and
then I saw punks and I was like you know
what I think I can do this that happened
really in like 2020 that was like in
January and uh started building out be
friends I always wanted to buy
Scooby-Doo or or Flintstones or Garfield
or Get Along Gang or Snorks and then
refurbish it and do what I'm doing now
with be friends but building my own
world is even more exciting and um it's
been really really powerful and you know
I have really big ambition like
obviously this comic we're making right
now like look what we're doing D you've
been around comics for a while like
we're literally making a comic right
this second that's gonna Inspire some
people to cancel four streaming services
and Postmates and they're going to save
$3,000 next year and that's going to
help their family have a better
Christmas or go on a vacation or or or
who the hell knows like something good
right like wasting money is not a good
idea and like I'm excited to make these
be friends provide value to the world
and I think that's what we're doing with
um um these comics and these stories and
kids books and animations and opening up
trading cards and you know I'm just
really excited about this journey I'm
really going to build something and
it's you know I think I think we got it
so I would say
2010 I thought about buying an IP like
Gumby or something like that 2015 I
thought about making my own workplace
Warriors like help people at work 2020
decided make characters to help the
whole world
period that's cool that's awesome yeah
uh similarly like I think back I heard
other comic strip artists talk about
this back in the day but like some
mentors and stuff like you want to draw
a comic strip that you want someone to
tear out and paste up on their fridge or
in their cubicle right like far side or
Garfield just to kind of that's how you
know like you've made it when you're
walking past a cubicle and you see that
your cartoon strip is plugged you know
in their office so that's kind of very
similar it definitely aligns with I'm
just so happy joury like when Landon
says this like I don't even like it
makes me want to
cry Andy like I mean like yeah like look
what Landon said like what else what
else can we doing Hayden's in the
building Hayden's got the it was
so fun watching uh courage last night oh
my God the G find rips do we know rips
oh what's
happening welcome
everybody um but yeah I just going to
shout out courage and I was seeing that
the happiness and joy on that live
stream last night and knowing that that
was created from be friends and the
amazing community and the people that
are watching right now means the world
to myself and I know it means a lot to
Gary and uh now DJ's gonna be alongside
it as we continue this journey and
bring bought that box from someone and
did you know that yeah insane he bought
the box from someone and the
disappointing part which I guess is a
running theme with him he actually
didn't break it
live he was opening it up and then he
was like damn it and then he hit the
live stream but that was awesome that's
awesome um girl with nfts we're thrilled
that you're a part of this community as
well I'm so proud of everybody like so
grateful for all of you again 20 minutes
until rips is on um
and demma wasn't able to make it to vcon
this year I'm excited to grow with
it was
empathy amazing rips had his first of
alcohol just now
wow Tune In Tune in at 555 for fanaic
live unbelievable anyway no I think um
yeah I love Fearless fairy too who's
everybody's favorite character actually
here's a fun one for the 350 people here
and the 550 people on Tik Tok
who who doesn't know much about vriends
at all like is just hanging right now
came from somewhere else like like just
say rookie say rookie in here
um because I think it's a lot of people
which is exciting too like it's the best
part for me just put rookie there we go
rookie is there a positive pit bull no
but there's a positive porcupine there's
a positive
porcupine tough to
beat rookie rookie rookie we got some
good Rooks in
here what's up son of Santiago Andy we
have to get everybody on Fanatics live
tonight I want to get all these people
free stuff tonight and we're giving away
so much tonight can everybody can
OG's in both Tik Tok and all these other
platforms if you're streaming if you're
in the chat please help people and link
up the link to Fanatics Live app um we
need people on for sure V friends can
drop in the official link to make sure
that you can download the app you're
going to have to download the app create
your username profile and then you'll be
able to join Connor con man Adam rips
for his birthday bash
celebration Gary V still bro vend
forever like nfts now trading cards like
vending machines Toys kids books coming
out I'm going to build a Marvel Pokemon
Sesame Street like brand and in 25 years
you're going to tell the story of this
exact moment when you were like I told
Gary ve like friendss come on Gary
vriends still like when your grandkid is
wearing vriends pajamas you're going to
be like that yeah
Marlene who's watching on LinkedIn right
now ask what is the best place to see
The Fanatic Live app download the app
I'm assuming if you're an iOS you can
just go to the App Store type in
Fanatics live you can download it
Marlene create your username and account
I would love to see you on the Fanatics
live I'm gonna I just screenshotted your
name
drop tell us that you came hey I love
you bro I'm just kidding
foot LinkedIn yeah we're streaming
everywhere mimo we're on X we're on
YouTube l a bomb big shout out
to the LinkedIn family mags NG I see
you yes chrish I would say yes
um man it's going to be fun tonight on
the
Stream
tiktock I love all of you thank you for
joining I love seeing the number keep
going up and up and up thank you so much
Billy always happy to spread the
knowledge I'm always sharing content
Gary any uh any Easter eggs you want to
throw a DJ to include in this or like
Easter eggs being I like the Practical
peacock streaming let me think seeing uh
accessories I mean I would say I would
say the DJ are you thinking about a v
friend delivering the bagel or you
thinking about a like a a
person yeah that could be a yeah get a
get a be friend from the audience to
swoop in and deliver the love that all
right everybody you heard the comic
story if you're just a lot of people are
just joining on Tik Tok there's now 800
people or so 700
um flexing
Fox flexing
Fox oh I have a big idea Andy Andy this
is the big
R I have a big
idea um for those of you
watching we are going to be live
tomorrow again finishing this comic with
Mr DJ Kaufman creator of VRI Comics um
we'll be live streaming for an hour
maybe more finalizing these
illustrations all right everybody and
start interrupt you got it because I got
to go to a meeting in a
second this is why everybody right now
especially the people on Tik Tok who
have no idea what's going
on Andy I just signed a cgc
10 10 10 cow and Hedgehog Fox is R
rarest one of the rarest ones for
everybody who knows I labeled them first
comic because they're featured in our
first comic I kind of want those you
could buy them on eBay once the person
who wins them for free tonight Dam on
Fanatics live them no I'm kidding
giveaways should we give two away should
we give these two away and auction off
the fox yeah okay I like that I gotta
give you something for your birthday all
right everybody who's on here especially
everyone on Tik Tok this is a free
giveaway this is massive this is like
real free dollars here you go
take that for the show Fanatics live the
link for everybody it's gary.com
fanatics1 1219 it's the Fanatics Live
app that's cool I need to help everyone
here on Tik Tok uh can I change the url
uh
ROV can can you open the
door ROV can you change my URL my
default URL on Tik Tok to Fanatics Live
app all right tell me when beautiful
that'll make it easy for everybody I'll
tell everybody on Tik Tok to just go to
my profile on Tik Tok and click the link
can we make a comic one day right now on
Tik Tok can you still do
it all right go ahead what's that end I
was requesting for a comic concept of
the joke of you needing to open your
door every two minutes because you need
to talk to someone outside of your
office I love that what's it uh I'm live
on everything Mark come live we're gonna
in here with you we surprise Mark
meeting is here Mark's come back here
you're gonna do the walk but I'm just
bring them in you do your thing got okay
you co it I'm super Co It intro and see
what's going on thank you
sgy yes shout out the 134 strong on
YouTube right
now
um any any uh any parting words yes The
Parting words is of the thousand people
between all the streams that are
watching you're insane if you don't get
Fanatics live on your app right now
download it and get ready for the show
it's going to be
bananas please everyone link it
up especially Tik Tok I'm worried about
Tik Tok because they most of them have
no idea what the going on right
now R off are you
good you switched it it's looking good
DJ all right now they're good Tik Tok
for all of you you can leave this live
right now go to my profile on Tik Tock
click the link as my default URL in my
profile that will send you to Fanatics
live download the app it's only for us
right now um Andy we need to make sure
we tweet out the link for international
to be able to watch on desktop
yep I see people helping each other
Jonathan is asking a very important
question but we will not be answering
that now but digital Comics coming this
is really
exciting looks so good great job DJ
what's the dialogue what's the first
dialogue let's see
that guys I don't know why I feel so
broke humble Hedgehog says let's figure
out your budget Common Sense cow I know
where to
start then she'll be like how many
streaming servic you are you gonna be
able to get this whole thing in four
tiles oh yeah that's he'll be naming his
uh all the services and I'm GNA find as
many as we possibly can it'll be
ridiculous and then down here they'll be
like what about
peacock maybe he doesn't have peacock
and so like peacock will be peeking in
and then the last either one of these
two panels will be the hey your Uber or
you're
uh the third one will be him on his
phone
seemingly de deleting all the services
like they're like oh good he's like okay
delete delete delete delete or
unsubscribe or cancel cancel cancel
cancel cancel and the last
one will have to be maybe a little bit
than that like yeah I kind of want like
they're excited you know it's almost
like this needs to be a five piler uh
Tyler one
but did you know five is my favorite
number like we might need to be a five
we might have to be a five company yeah
you got to think about the single image
too but anyway punchline the last one is
it's seemingly he's cancelling all these
apps but he's also quickly ordering a
bagel on Uber Eats and so like they're
excited that he saved all this money but
then the $40
Bagel right so that'll be the receipt or
like it might not be a closeup of the
receipt but I got an idea for you Gary
we could have a SE we could have like a
secret fifth panel that you reveal
somewhere else like you could be like
this is the alternate the alternate
panel I like that you know I like that
yeah the $40 Bagel is when you order a
bagel in Manhattan Andy you know this
you've done this I know you you you
order some food for some you
got to admit
it
I'm not admitting anything so you've
been good and yeah I'm I'm very
practical peacock you're Frugal I'm
Frugal nice because you know I like will
order a coffee when we're working and
it's like $21 for a coffee
because I need a Dunkin' donuts and you
got to pay this that the other thing
it's crazy but the r the ROI of that $40
coffee to keep the engine going and save
you time Keegan it's really close
Keegan's like is it really 40 bucks it's
close
it's
Hannah a bagel when you order it on
seamless it's like 30 bucks right if you
get like an everything bagel with locks
with the delivery and the SE charge of
the post it's 30
right is it
more it's about 30 yeah man it's a
$30 Bagel
bro make it 30 uh when you make the
final total DJ make it 3555 I like the
fives oh all right
I'll write it down
35 what's good wax walls hope you're
super well happy holidays brother hope
you're really good hope everything's
amazing
um all right thank you you sure the
Miami office is gonna be
awesome
doig all right I think I need to
go yeah D you keep working with Andy I
love you Andy make sure that everybody
gets to Fanatics live in eight
minutes DJ I love you we'll be seeing
you a bunch everybody say thank you to
DJ we'll see you soon um Tik Tac I love
you thank you for hanging with me uh
Fanatics live make sure you get on it
the link is in my profile right now go
have fun go get a bunch of free for
your stocking stuffers uh for gifts and
definitely learn about this world it's
going crazy uh I love
you
D we'll we'll hang out for another like
six minutes or so while we're waiting uh
for them to kick on Fanatics live and I
think Gary's gonna drop him
second yeah this is fun I know I'm quiet
but you know figure out how to make this
fox this fox counting his fingers you
know I gotta figure out how many how
many vriend characters do you think
you've drawn thus far in your
professional career
10 uh sketch wise let me see like
uh one two three four five 6 7 8 9 10
13 and then all the ones that were in
the first 14 15
16 17
and are they about all equal in terms of
like really trying to nail the look and
feel and character is like the fox take
more just because he has the chain and
the
sunglasses no I I think that like they
all have a different shape like I can
see the patterns like uh the Hedgehog
has a very panda body you know what I
mean and I could see the patterns that
like certain characters have and then
like they're odd-shaped heads so like
generous gerbal has like a you know a
head that kind of looks like this
right kind of like that shape right
think right and then he's got like the
yeah crazy trying to
remember yeah and then he's got like a
pattern that comes into his
nose and then he's got those like crazy
crazy cheeks or smiling yeah so once you
start to learn the pattern of like oh
this one's just like that one kind of
they're from the same little uh you know
Universe I
guess
chains just said I need a new pfp now I
like that fox that could be a fun stream
we do one day where it's literally just
taking requests for different profile
pictures and we do some custom profile
pictures of different
characters yeah that'd be
fun like the jal's just kind of peeking
into that panel now Andy people people
really gonna get to know the characters
through this stuff you know like all
justed thank you I mean it's just
everyone's GNA be excited for this to
come out too yeah every day and like
honestly I think we're going to help
people just like my content that you and
I worked on for a decade like this is a
comic like when this comic comes out
tomorrow or first thing in the following
morning obviously we're just getting our
bearings next year's the official year
yeah like I I genuinely think a lot of
people that are on this stream right now
are gonna forward it to their most loose
with money friend like this is like a
fun thing like a dad to put in a family
thread because their kid keeps asking
for money because they use unlimited
Uber mates have six streaming services
like you know what I mean
100% daily Comics I think there's going
to be some weekly themes with key
characters that are Roven throughout
that week and the the topics in subject
matters we're really trying to
storytelling to be live streaming and
interacting next
year specifically in January we'll be
live on Thursdays for the most part but
we're going to continue to flow based on
when the fans and audience are going to
be there when we can have Gary join and
how DJ's feeling about balancing between
being live and just the daily output of
comics that we want to get
out yeah I'm out of here see you thanks
thanks
G yeah it's fun I think we'll try to be
as live as much as possible like he said
like even if it's just a stream where
I'm not interacting maybe just like
going completely just like here's my
screen this is me drawing you can drop
in the chat and kind of interact with us
it's fun
100% we got
the fox counting on his fingers here
like how many he's G to have and I'm
gonna make I'm gonna make as many as
possible there's going to be so many
streaming
services we'll swap this around we'll
swap that from from there there to there
yeah
yeah we
good Jared Jacobson law you're awesome
DJ keep it up thanks for dropping by
jar Keegan I will be a guest um
any email me and V friends I know we
talked about it before but I'll join
again yeah January Let's Do
It
um we are going to close down the live
here in a couple minutes DJ is gonna
kick back up tomorrow I'm gonna join him
uh in the beginning just to say hello to
everybody 12 pm Eastern we're going to
be drawing be friends Comics be friends
Comics is the name of the show
tomorrow and then of course in two
minutes time there's about to be
pandemonium at vriend HQ as Adam and the
crew uh celebrate his 21st birthday but
also uh have a great Fanatics live I
think they have some fun things in store
Gary just signed these three characters
which are being featured in the first
ever be friends comic he signed them
first uh comic Edition which will be
really exciting and other than that DJ
I'll kick it over to you for
Last Words thoughts questions uh from
the community that you want to take um
and we can say
goodbye yeah no I'm just excited to be
here I'm excited to draw these
characters and you know engage with you
guys as much as possible so thanks for
watching and yeah we'll be back tomorrow
at noon drawing some stuff so yeah and I
I'll give I want to give claps and Kudos
and credit to DJ the way he applied I
think a lot of people could take lessons
from he immediately took action he
started live streaming drawing it to the
point where he didn't even need to apply
I actually reached out to him because it
uh crossed my attention that he was
doing a live live stream with be friends
Comics so kudos to you DJ and I'm really
excited about what we have in store with
be friends comics for
2024 right on man yeah I'm excited
thanks DJ thanks everyone for watching
see you guys soon have fun up there
download it see you guys take care
byebye